Усе це виготовили лише для того, щоб… викинути.
Пластикові упаковки. Щороку у світі викидається
понад 100 мільйонів тонн.
Пластикове сміття дедалі більше забруднює довкілля.
Ці зернята могли б поліпшити ситуацію.
Принаймні так стверджує цей чоловік.
Адже пластик можна розплавити
і використовувати повторно.
Це чистий поліетилен.
Візьмімо кросівки: підошва з поліетилену - відходів поліетиленової плівки.
Пластик - це дуже гнучка сировина.
Під дією температури йому можна надати будь-яких форм.
Ідея Міхаеля Гофманна - піддавати пластик вторинній переробці.
Проблема лише в тому, що саме сортування сміття дуже затратне.
Раніше цю брудну роботу брав на себе Китай.
Тут скуповували за безцінь сміття з цілого світу,
аби відсортувати з нього дорогу сировину та матеріали.
Однак тепер влада країни це заборонила.
І в німецьких сміттярів виникла проблема:
куди подіти сміття?
Ціни на сміття впали, бо Азія загалом і Китай зокрема
раніше платити дуже добру ціну за цю сировину,
а тепер падіння збуту в Китай
призводить до того, що сміття накопичується в Європі.
Тож, це шанс для європейських переробників.
З огляду на це винахід Міхаеля Гофманна може себе окупити.
Це свого роду величезна пральна машина для пластику.
Установка коштує близько 600 тисяч євро.
Підприємство хоче вийти з цією машиною на світовий ринок.
Лише два відсотки поліетиленових плівок у світі переробляються.
Тому що цю сировину дуже важко піддавати переробці.
А саме поліетилену викидають 80-90 мільйонів тонн у світі щорічно,
і він є найбільшим забрудником світових вод.
Такими поліетиленові плівки виходять з пральні -  чисті та тоненькі.
Далі їх переробляють на гранулят,
який, до речі, користується великим попитом у тому ж Китаї.
Та чи вирішить це проблему німецьких сміттєпереробників?
Просто весь пластик у нову пральну машину?
Не все так просто.
Це рішення лише для плівок,
які майже стовідсотково складаються з поліетилену.
Але є багато речовин, які складаються з різних видів пластику.
Тобто пластик буває різним.
Якщо в ході виробництва різні види пластику змішують,
його неможливо потім переробити.
У Німеччині все ще понад половина усіх пластикових відходів просто спалюється.